we're talking about skirting boards when
it comes to Interior Design it's not
just about what's at eye level it's also
about all the little details that
connect everything seamlessly have you
ever walked into a room with beautiful
hardwood floors only to be met with a
skirting that just doesn't match it's a
common oversight but here's the thing
skirting plays a significant role in the
overall Aesthetics of a space mismatched
or cheap skirtings can disrupt the
harmony of your entire H so let's
consider an alternative
matching your skirtings with your
hardwood floors it's a subtle yet
impactful design Choice when the
skirting seamlessly flows from the floor
it creates a sense of continuity
elegance and sophistication